so I I was sort of raised in the Puerto
Rican community at home politically and
so we and we came here for a long time
both for business and pleasure since
you're part of the third Circuit Court
of Appeals and Delaware as well and I
was chairman of Judiciary Committee I
spent a lot of time in the northern part
of the state
I think it's meaningless dribble every
word that comes out of his mouth yes he
was raised in the Puerto Rican Community
politically what does that mean it means
absolutely nothing I actually do want to
throw back to it it's only 10 seconds
because look at Jill Biden this this
woman who you know she's worse than him
because she knows what's going on and
she's abusing him and using him and all
of that stuff and she's probably banging
Gavin Newsom on the side
um their little breaking news for you
but look at her face the entire time
because she knows everything he says is
nonsense she knows he can't read the
teleprompter correctly and she knows
he's always one breath away from the
entire thing breaking down look at the
soulless look in her face and so I uh I
was sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home politically and so we
and we came here for a long time both
for business and pleasure since you're
part of the third Circuit Court of
Appeals and Delaware is as well and I
was chairman of Judiciary Committee
until Dr Jill paging Dr Jill Jesus uh
but there's more if you want to see just
the endless woke nonsense from these
people here's Biden at a Hispanic
heritage event uh from Davis from a day
or two ago
[Applause]
dreamers can you imagine maybe some of
you were dreamers
it's like I don't know what people
expect to say when your mom's taking
your cross the Rio Grande and say no Mom
I'm staying here I'm not going I'm going
to make my choice come on this is
bizarre
the temporary status holders Farm
Workers and essential workers as well
okay I'm not even sure what his point
was there it was something about the
fact that you know the dreamers are the
kids who come from illegal immigrants
that are here something like that they
wouldn't want to say that they don't
want to come he's just everything with
these people it's just the worst sort of
pandering and ugh
all right
there you go how did this guy become
president what what did we do to deserve
this what did we do